my name is lou hartwig the project to
deal with my good friend Andy Fisher and
so real quick the premise here is you
know so sports like baseball and
basketball football they have really
great statistics and for rowing there
are virtually none and so this kind of
game of conversation and we sought to
bring some some sort of standard to this
project so we're again real quick my
name is Lou
I am the CTO and co-founder at skidaddle
which is a crowd-sourced transportation
platform we had a bit of news beginning
of this year we helped 10,000 people to
go to and from the women's market in DC
in a single weekend currently a big
thing that we have going on is Penn
Station in New York is shutting down for
emergency repairs so we're helping
people from towns in New Jersey to get
to and from the city every day on top of
normal day-to-day business of helping
people get the beach's events wherever
they want to go private events like
weddings and things like that and so
there's a little code there for five
dollars off your first ride and then
let's click back on Andy he just
recently got his PhD in biomedical
engineering from bu and he's currently a
postdoc researcher there and then Andy
found a picture of us around together
book handing in the guy in the middle
there all right
so quickly to you know go through the
outline here we're going to go through
why we did this project some basic
terminology and rowing how we got the
data how we had to clean the data and
then finally going into the houses video
alright so back in March I was doing a
workout and afterwards there happened to
be a few Lincoln's there who were
talking about the current state of us
rolling which is the national governing
body for rowing they organized a
national team all the races and whatnot
and their us drawling is having a bit of
trouble with their organization and
retention of employees and they were
really focusing on that and then at one
point they started to touch upon the
difference in successful is between the
women's and men's teams at the Olympic
level and the women's team has been very
dominant for
the past 11 years they've won every
major regatta and the men's team has not
had that same level of success and so
the these Olympic athletes who are all
domain experts were tossing around
somewhat sometimes assumptions about the
transition rate between the end of 23
national team which is basically you
know the elite level collegiate rowing
to the senior national team and the
Olympic team and at that point I kind of
something attention because I was
thinking oh hold on like you know does
this change year to year does this
change per country you know how's this
what are the trends in this I mean how
can we find this data and so then that
led to you know World Rowing and we lose
the whole foundation of the stock so a
little bit of let's see this so I'm not
sure it has has anyone here tried rowing
or seen rowing I know Seattle's a big
rowing area with you know University of
Washington is very dominant the sport
boys in the boat was written about a
team meal from way back in the day from
here so this is a really great area for
it but in just in case you people have
not heard about it let's quickly go
through some basic terminology here so
so you show up that our worlds are got
you have you know the name of the
regatta you know it could be the like
this one right here 2009 World
Championships there are a whole variety
of races there's men's races women's
races there are lightweight and
heavyweight there are fours eight
doubles pairs singles Enzo what are
these terms mean you see people here
they rode tours and people rode with one
or some people have a coxswain steering
the boat then the boats without a Coxon
if they have multiple people in it
there's actually the the rudder is
attached to someone's foot and so they
have to steer with their foot as they're
paying attention going as far as they
can be that backwards so yeah there's
all there's a whole variety of different
skills going around here so I'm just
going to you know quickly is with some
some data that we'll talk about how we
got later on but just to quickly go
through the boat class column here we
see there's all these different ways to
describe the boat
but some basic patterns we can see here
are you know it's you know it could
start off with a be like so they're a
little go through rosy rose example so
BM 4x so that what is that saying is you
know the B stigmatizes the e 23 event so
there's a couple others like that row 13
and 14
so that's a 23 event you know you know
everyone's under 23 years old yeah
obviously so at the end for men and then
for X you know there are four rowers and
there's a skilling boat so each roller
has two oars below that you know M two
plus you know it again a men's boat
there are two rollers and the plus
signifies that there's a [ __ ] since
during the boat - was safety no it's a
it's a straight boat there's no Coxon
one of the rowers has a rudder attached
to their foot and so then if we go down
the list you know jw4 - it's a junior
lumens straight forward so there's no
Coxon so junior woman's boat so everyone
is under 19 so pretty straightforward
you know there's as we get into
Paralympics there's some some other
letters you get that get added and so it
gets a little more complicated with that
but for the focus of this talk we
decided to stick with just the world's
racing Olympic racing on a 23 engineer
again just a quickly show you know so
there's exact upper columns here but
like what what kind of data we're
looking at so you know we ship the
regatta takes place in the you know we
can see what city and country it is the
name is what year it is not too much
else going on there it's pretty straight
forward and the races and others you
know there's a bunch of boats that are
entered so there could be heat and
finals there could be semi-final squirty
finals seeding races so we've to go
through and clean all this data to bring
some standards here so just to sum all
that back up
there's scaling and sweep which really
just says how many horses each row or
have the plus and minus says there is a
Coxon or not
and then you can see in the scaling
boats you know you can have any the one
extant one person you can obviously have
one or one person that was just going
circles but then the rest of it is
fairly straightforward and then you know
in front of that there may be you know
an Emer w based on men or women and then
you know be a J if it's a light weight
event there's an L so not not too
complicated but just to really hammer
that home so we can understand that
moving forward one last time going
through so men women open like a
lightweight open weight so we've already
discussed that a bunch then there's heat
repechage quarterfinal semifinal and
then there's a whole list of finals and
if it's a big event say for example the
single you know the men's or women's
single out the Olympics there could be a
huge number of entries and so there
could be the seeding of race and then
their quarterfinal to the semi-final and
then you have representation it to the
semi-final and so there's a pat that
isn't always straightforward to make it
to a final all right so now we get into
data collection
you know most these libraries I think
everyone's use not sure as any of
everyone here you use network X before
for graphing so that was my first time
using was just written is actually cool
I really enjoy using that and then we
just did something diagrams to put in
that plot with them so you can see these
are really standard URLs when you browse
the page on your web browser it goes and
it depends the name of the person app at
the end but we can take that off and
Glee's to get the same results now we
can move through take that number out 86
39 and we can just loop through until we
stop seeing people show up basically we
just loop through this until we 404 a
bunch of times we know that there's no
longer any data the the trouble we ran
into as we started digging into this is
that there are pockets and sections of
missing IDs and so if you see 10 missing
IDs in a row or 30 or 40 that doesn't
mean that it's ended so we saw that 50
thousand is a good number too
and so we went to - mm and then you know
towards the end there there were more
and more missing IDs but there's still
be the occasional athlete showing up so
we had to account for all of that so the
web page is broken down the two
important sections the first one is like
right here the athlete bio has important
information what's the name agenda birth
date height weight a few other things
that we collected just to you know see
if they would be useful nothing -
nothing too crazy here this is what
really gets interesting though because
each athlete has their own page of this
information so now we have to make sense
of thousands of these pages and tie it
all together and say who is rolling with
who at which race how do they do how
does the final ranked who is more
successful and so that's what it's sort
of get a little complicated so quickly
running through terminology you can see
here's the regatta
here's each individual race and then we
go through okay so there's a boat class
country here's you know the final semi
final heats the rank and then final time
scrape the athlete's data it's pretty
straightforward
we saw some problems with graphing HTML
tags that could say you know a year or
you know birthday or birthday and then
they put you know the city of they're
occasionally so there's no standard
whatsoever to how well drawings stored
the data and so at times I was
frustrating but we push through it again
right I saw this but just a you know
review the schema once more if the
athletes get the race that athlete races
the tie those two together and then you
get the ricotta and then we can say
which athlete was at what regatta real
simple we just loop through the few
functions we hack together 50,000 times
to grab all the athlete ID all their
gotta race ID to information apologize
for the block of text I should have
broken this down especially since we
just went through a whole thing data
cleanliness
in here so this is and this is really
basic you can see line 27 grab the URL
and certain ID in there each time if it
doesn't return a 404 grab all the
information you possibly can from the
bio and at the time we weren't really
sure because no one was defining this
project other than us and you know what
type of data do we want to collect you
and we may be useful later so that was
pretty straightforward again so regatta
is and once we grab the athlete we say
okay luckily the regatta and racing
throw was all in an HTML table so you
could say which ergot is on the page and
then within that which races of the
athlete competing at that regatta and so
that's where this really gets
interesting is now we have to say okay
we have this regatta luckily all the
divers were in the same format listed
even if the names naming conventions
changed over time
so we could say did we have you already
seen this regatta if yes we get the ID
if no yet we add it so really
straightforward there same thing with
the races we say this athlete did this
race have we seen this race before yes
grab PID know add it to the table and
then we at Lisa's we say grab that ID
grab the authority credit record all
right so data cleaning so this is really
rare and so if you look at a fleet ID
one this is what my activism died so
they were born 1985 in the first race is
1978 and this is really common for this
whole database it just it just didn't
stop and like at a I don't know I mean
we hopefully by the end of this we can
work with World Rowing and maybe we can
you know you know point out some areas
for improvement at the end but this was
definitely a struggle for us for quite a
while was cleaning the data and seeing
how we can improve it we wanted to
standardize all the names so you can see
here in that first method you know we
worked with one of the Olympians I
originally mentioned in the beginning
there as a domain expert so that's how
we know that nation's cup is actually 23
we got up with any other ones
they all virtually say the same thing
but we wanted to calm was to make sense
of that just so we didn't think about
that later World Championships stayed
the same throughout the rest of them
there tends to be world run cups all had
the same format but they're just having
multiple through each season usually
three I think the highest I got there
was six so yet you know that was pretty
standard as well they got a lot more
complicated just tedious with the the
semifinals there's a some naming
differences there you can see in my
comments here I saw digging through data
that the finals weren't always listed as
final a is the a final so if there's
only one final once we saw that it was
those F final and that really was more
distrust of the data so just going
through really you know simple just
adding a column saying is this a heat
semi-final final a couple others so then
breaking this down so we have a just
helper function as we head to at the
every time we started this project up
one to explore and test the new things
we said okay just run this function well
we had a separate file all together and
we'd say loading the data frames you
know my fault and I scraped I
accidentally added X extra columns and
then apply these helper functions and so
now it's just really straightforward
plug and play what's going on okay like
you know so this last line and show you
but you know is a sculling event hedges
it's about have a Coxon what are the
number of rowers here so just further
cleaning the data and providing a
standard all right so this is where we
start to look at the data and we were
saying okay well you know what what can
we make sense of here and we still don't
know what is good data or bad data we're
still plugging through and working
through that and so you see things like
this and you wonder what happened in
1984 but I think part of it is though
the URL here you know World Rowing com
it's you know they didn't really come
about until the late 90s early 2000s and
so they're back to link data before that
so they may have just used a filler you
know so we're still exploring the how
and the why there but yeah I mean that
was that was definitely an interesting
graph to pull through and then the other
thing we see here is any other increase
in the number of women over time want
some things you know that really pull
through with that so title 9 really
allowing women to compete at a
collegiate level that really improved
the quality of sport especially in the
US and out of the US women are very
dominant and I mean every one of them
say I have heard lots people say you
know title nine is shown it's good
strength
so in this more data here you have a you
know the heights again this is all
fairly standard accepting you can
Tennessee at the book ends we there are
some ridiculous heights here so we we
counted a number of athletes above three
meters for 87 and number of athletes
shorter than one meter we're 13 so
that's just wrong I mean it's a perfect
so yeah it's a we're still making sense
of what data to trust I mean I think we
saw that maybe the athlete bio
information was bad but they you know
the boat itself the athlete and you know
the races they participated in was good
so we were trying to we're still trying
to push our way through all that so it
we're getting there it's really
scratching the surface with what we can
do to analyzes data again you know
roller Heights size over time we saw as
you know as we get into the early
two-thousands there's a dip and actually
what that is is that there's mainly
junior athletes at that age or you know
coming onto this website at the first as
you know the first time
and yet they're still growing I mean
they're still ended up you know they're
not super old yet so yeah you know
they're not at full height all the time
so we can see that tip right there
so well in these you know here's really
I know what we really wanted to find out
and you know quick note and this is a
map plot live been pretty cool package
and really easy to use
but yeah just count out the number of
athletes and saying okay can we see
trends with this data or you can see you
know being a junior athlete you know
across the board doesn't have a bearing
on making it to the Olympics you know
there's a lot of other factors that go
into plate with that I mean that doesn't
mean that you should you know try but it
just that was the first thing we saw and
we broke it down by country and by a
success level further down but we wanted
to see like if you if you were in the
one group you know did that have an
effect necessarily and be in another
group and so we also looked at you know
yes you know so their Olympic seven once
every four years and there's plenty of
other athletes who race at World Cups
only or World Cups or championships
so you can be a senior athlete and not
make it to the Olympics and so we didn't
account for that in this diagram but I
believe in this table we did yeah you
know so the count of athletes who did
and yet worlds and Olympics near 3300 so
so yeah it does have an effect you know
there that the graph would be a little
bit different but you know still being a
junior or didn't have a major effect on
you know whether you make it to the
senior team or not I mean you are
rolling at a u23 level had a greater
effect on making it to the world's level
the senior level though so that was
interesting playing again like you're
these athletes to be more fully
developed at college age and this is a
sport where you're just spending hours
and hours doing volume training at the
Olympic level they're spending
you know six or seven hours a day
training and then the race itself at the
final is around six minutes so over the
course of four years they could be
spending dozens of hours for every
stroke of that final race just training
away and so it's a really brutal sport
given how much time you put in for the
final race so further analysis here you
know this is something we got looking to
as well is so the number of Olympians
for the US is significantly higher than
the other countries yeah we were
inclined to think that it's not that it
may not be true and we want to know take
a look at okay so we need to do an
analysis of which boats competed at
these events and then New York as
opposed to looking at this from the
athlete level take a look from the the
boat level and say which boats competed
at these events because there are are
instances where the boat may have
missing athletes they're just missing
data so we we need to account for this
so you can see I mean that the biggest
part of this whole project was data
collection that data cleaning and we've
been digging further and further into
the the analysis section here but you
know it's definitely exciting to see the
numbers pull through and we're leaving
at Ludovic and we really like to work
with World Rowing comm to clean this
data up and then from there do further
analysis they have sections on their
pages for speed and you know the stroke
rate data so how fast the boats are
moving and how many strokes per minute
are the rowing at so not you know to be
it'd be great to see changes in trends
of that over time as well but first we
wanted to really hammer through this so
to quickly sum this up we see that
there's a huge difference between the
number of Olympians in the USA versus
everywhere else
and that we try to look at that trend
again from Elvis female again number one
both male female but then number of
Olympians with junior experience and we
drop down so we need to inspect the
quality of the data first but you know
for the athlete count but it is
interesting that even though the athlete
count is so much higher for number of
Olympians in the u.s. that the u.s. is
much lower in a number of athletes that
convert from junior to senior team and
so that's the question that you know so
maybe these athletes burn out and I
personally have had several friends who
completely burnt out because they just
over trained when they're a teenager and
hated it so you know that that you know
that could be a factor it really there's
there's a whole lot going on here I know
from people telling me that other
countries tend to pay their athletes
more where in the u.s. they make you
know under ten thousand dollars a year
and you know they some of these people
went to Ivy League schools and they need
to get a job so it really depends on you
know a few factors there of why they
didn't make it from the junior team to
the senior team again we can't take a
look here so Junior experience did it
have an effect on top of luck eight
boats just single decade not you know
any of the other pro classes and we see
I mean not really you know it's kind of
all over the place here there's no
distribution there's no likeness a trend
there so it I mean look at the line next
slide as well easy this is quickly u23
so you can see roughly they're about the
same you know there's no necessarily
trend here it's just
yeah we as always an Asterix with this
knee we need to figure out why the data
isn't standard in certain areas before
we make final assumptions here of why
the data looks a certain way so you know
they're you know given the data we have
we were given we didn't see that rowing
at a certain level as a young kid or the
collegiate level meant that you'd be an
Olympic champion so this is you know
this is really another area of interest
that we just started to stumble upon
last week we wanted to see it basically
just building a graph this is our
network X comes into play as a you know
Khaleesi well whose road with who in the
in which boats can we see over time if
we add weights to these edges you know
how successful certain combinations were
you know could we see these two or three
people were far more successful and then
the others and that's a tough problem
because you don't necessarily know what
other countries are doing and to
prioritize their boats and so now you
have this task where you say I need to
maximize you know these boats in this
order and the other I have no idea what
order the other teams are prioritizing
their boats and so that could work out
in your favor might not but you know we
just started to really scratch the
surface on this uh in the past few days
here you know just I'll start get into
the graphs you know so this intuitively
this makes sense I mean you know people
who wrote in the Romans 8 when it first
became an event in the longer row in
that boat and so you can see over time
you know if we start at one section of
the graph people row with each other and
then some people tire new people joining
the boat and that continues to happen
over time and then you get to the
current athletes and so this you know
this one you know may have sense to me
it was actually the
a graph which I thought was surprising
there's a lot of disconnected segments
here and I guess you know the you know
the people wrote together as an eight
and then they stopped occasionally there
was some connectivity going on you still
need to get a cluster and I believe that
is more recent athletes so what's going
on with the athletes from some period of
time ago why do they wrote just one so
we need to inspect that and so this may
help us figure out what's going on here
with the data why are some athletes only
listen here once is just an error it's a
mistake or they're missing athletes you
know that could have connected this
graph even more so what you know how
we're taking a look at this and saying
how can we really dive in here and see
what's going on and the other thing to
note if you go back and this is a much
newer event for the women compared to
the men so the athletes and this
database are very old and you know it's
no fault of roller ENCOM and they may
have just it may be really difficult to
get that data now you not know in the
non Olympic year what what they were
doing you know who who is in the boat
you have an old picture yet they get the
guess you maybe try to dig in and call
someone but that's still difficult and
so again you know these are GPRS a Great
Britain very similar you know this more
more do this one's a little more
connected for men and then women it's a
similar thing where it's in kind of a
semicircle and then I think I had one
more team in here yep Canada so again
you see for the men cluster and then you
see some sections around the edge where
they wrote once as a group and that was
it the women's graph for Canada is
interesting you see there's one node
that is connected it has many many edges
so we couldn't get
the data for who the toxin was in this
media we had the the data was available
if we go way back to the beginning on
that regatta page you see that there was
a link you could see the boat lineup but
that was I was opening up a whole other
can of worms of going to a separate page
on that website and trying to deal with
that data as well and we just said that
it's not worth it so that could be a
Coxon who was rowing for quite a while
and it's not nearly as much of a fickle
physical toll in the body to sit in the
boat and in steer and coach them through
a race is still taxing that squeeze into
that seat and it has the boat as the
oars a you know enter the water and the
rowers call to go all the way back up to
the front of the slide to put the blade
and sometimes it can be a stop and go
and so that can be drawing on their back
and so that over time it is physically
demanding fork actions as well but it is
not not at the same level so it could
have been that could have been that and
we haven't built this out yet enough to
really drill a drill into you know who
has the most edges in the Oh like really
analyzing these graphs yeah we may we've
built these in the basketball days and
we were just trying to see what we could
find here and there's so much more we
could do with this there's so much more
we can do with you know the other
sections I'm chairing the data science
conference everyone's thinking oh my god
like why didn't do that like there's
there's so much we can do with this and
we're really looking forward to it and
the tough part is you know this does not
is there's nothing to do my day job
there's nothing to it his day job so we
work on nights and weekends whenever
we're both around and so it's you know
we're having fun with it and exploring
whatever we can but you know so you know
on to that you know what are the next
steps here we want to see retention
rates of athletes Junior u23 development
to really drill into that as I said
before examine you know nothing's from
the athlete level from the boat level
okay so final the boats that missing
athletes I know I mean I've seen that
that exists we just haven't had time to
examine that yet and that's I think
that'll be very telling and seeing which
you know does that vary by country which
which teams have missing athletes or is
it no more
or older races that we're just missing
data so I think that that's something to
examine as well how does that affect the
data we're looking at I mean would it be
easier for us is to say everything from
1999 earlier it was just out at lycée
it's not what useful to us and we want
to examine modern-day rolling with any
of the newest blades and the newer
technology is that we want to examine or
we try to examine the entire data set we
initially want to do the entire data set
but we've tossed around the idea of
throwing out a good portion of the data
just a you know enforce a standard here
now as you guys can see from my scraping
code the scripting process has to
improve we need something that's easily
repeatable and probably stored in a
database this is relational data
this again is a basic feature
engineering going is another big thing
and then you know the last part I
thought this is interesting is it
actually was what started out the whole
network analysis here is a you know I
was sitting with that the domain expert
and you know see how it'd be cool to see
you like in your who in which boat is
there you know the power player are the
power subgroups and I mean huge thing
only had that you know that's cool but
it would be so hard to see that because
you have no idea what's going on the
other team and maybe they didn't put
their best athletes in that boat you
know people the team for your prioritize
what they're their top photos and that
changes things around quite a bit and so
then you guys we think about that you
know one thing to think about if you
guys have red boys in the boat to go
quite in-depth in that book about how
it's not just about the putting the
strongest people on the boat but the
people who wrote best together in the
boat and so you can get more data on you
know who has the best scores in the
rowing machine but that doesn't always
equate to who is the best in the water
this is a sport where you put the blade
in and this coach is counting number
frames on the camera how fast you do
that and at the same times everyone else
and then pushing forward you know when
you know you're really driving your legs
down and just levering the boat bending
the oar and launching it forward and so
doing that completely and harmony is is
very difficult that's why these athletes
spend so many hours training to do that
and so that's something this book
touches upon and but we're saying how
can we measure this you know is that
something where we can say okay we built
some sort of ranking system with this
graph when we say you know here the most
successful athletes in this eight and so
we can you know make an assumption about
how and maybe maybe the better athletes
in the eight and so that we stumbled
upon this thing you know called a
weighted synergy graph and this is
actually done in 2013 and some follow-up
brokers done 2015 but basically it's
saying okay the strength of the team is
not just the sum of the individual
components but they know that how well
they work together and this is
originally done with robots specifically
about urban disaster recovery but then
they mention in there that it could
easily be extrapolated to teams you know
and human tasks and then they owe
someone to follow-up work about that
with MBA teams and they said uh
examining the zero-sum games where
there's a winner and a loser and both
teams are trying to put their best five
men or women out there how does you know
this team who are the best given that
they're also trying to find their best
and so that was it's something we're
digging into now is how can we apply
this to you know a six boat race where
everyone's trying to do the same thing
and everyone trying to put their best
people forward and who are those deaf
people all right and that was it any
questions
[Applause]
questions
yeah I'll ask so you said you did
cleaning the data was a real challenge
and most of the work yeah
so what did you learn or what kinds of
lessons are there about cleaning data
that could be applied patients to other
any techniques technologies rules of
thumb so I used a beautiful soup and
request to get the data and then from
there it was a I mean there's probably a
better way but I because I was scraping
fifty thousand athletes and I threw this
up on an etq server where I start the
job before work and I would see if it
was done after work that means you know
there was a good chunk of time where it
could break and so what I would do is I
would you know every 500 lines or so of
processing I'd just create an output
saying alright here's where I'm at and
then anytime I have four or four I'd log
that to this status file and so you used
if people here probably familiar with
team box so I just you know gone into
going you know to start down to the team
work session log off go to work on my
lunch break I can login see what line
it's at in this static text file I you
know cat the files using at the last
line is it still working or whatnot and
that way and then periodically I would
save the data and then that way I knew
if something broke halfway through the
day I'd have a starting point again I
could just say okay load this data then
continue forward one thing I really it
got me twice before I caught it in just
in different sections was special
characters you know if you have a race
somewhere in Europe or Asia and there
could be special characters and the
names of you know the athletes and the
names of where the country is and so
catching that and using I think I DTF I
think is what handles that SOI add just
making sure anytime I grab data I
convert it right away before I saved it
and that way I didn't break just things
like that it was really just one at a
time just you know okay I hit this
problem okay fix it now I hit this
problem and but
you know I'm trying to patch it and
looking everywhere else where it where's
this where's this bug can I find it
again but giving myself a low status
output and saving whatever possible
really help a lot
any other questions all right one quick
update in addition to there being snacks
outside there's going to be a lightning
talk sign-up sheet you can go sign up if
you want to give a quick 5 minute talk
the the pod data crew will go through
that and will people will let you know
whether quickly so make sure you put
your make sure you put a an email
address that you will check down in the
list otherwise Lou thank you for a great
presentation
[Applause]